boaters got their first extended look at
an historically diverse field of
Democratic presidential hopefuls in a
prime-time TV debate last night deduced
after watch 10 candidates talked for two
hours agreeing on most of the most of
the important issues but highlighting
their differences in policy ideas and
more candidates including Joe Biden
Bernie Sanders Kamala Harris and Pete
Budaj
will take the same stage tonight at
O'Keefe is in Miami where he covered
last night's debate he's got a bit of
laryngitis but he still has something to
say ed what stood out for you well there
seemed to be a sense of relief last
night that the party got through a
substantive debate free of any real
nastiness one name that didn't come up
much president Trump instead the
Democrats focused on their own ideas
when you've got an economy that does
great for those with money and isn't
doing great for everyone else that is
corruption pure and simple
with the first answer of the night
senator Elizabeth Warren set the tone we
need to make structural change in our
government in our economy and in our
country but the economy is something
that ten candidates agree on I live in a
low income black and brown community I
see every single day that this economy
is not working for average Americans the
bottom 60% haven't seen a raise since
1980 there was less common ground on how
to fix complex problems like health care
who here would abolish their private
health insurance in favor of a
government-run plan just a show of hands
start out with i'm with bernie on
medicare for all and let me tell you why
i've spent a big chunk of my life
studying why families go broke and one
of the number one reasons is the cost of
health care i am just simply concerned
about kicking half of america off of
their health insurance when it came to
the crisis on the border fathers and
mothers and children are dying if you
were president today what would you
specifically do i became the first
candidate to put forward a comprehensive
immigration plan and we saw those images
watching that image of Volkov and his
daughter Valeria is heartbreaking
it should also piss us all off former
housing secretary who Leon Castro
challenged his rival to end the
criminalization of illegal border
crossings some like congressman O'Rourke
have not and I want to challenge all of
the candidates to do that I just think
it's a mistake I think it's a mistake I
helped to introduce legislation that
would ensure that we don't criminalize
those who are seeking asylum and refuge
in this country if you're clean if
you're violent then I want to make sure
speaking to viewers watching on Spanish
television some of the candidates
delivered bilingual answers me llamo
Julian Castro
yes toy pastelon dope or Presidente de
los Estados Unidos vamos a tratar
calliper sona con el respeto situatio
horas in acceptable it was a historic
night never before had three women been
on a stage at a presidential debate who
has passed a law protecting a woman's
right a reproductive health and health
insurance I just want to say there's
three women up here that have fought
pretty hard for a woman's right to
choose one other name weeding here last
night former Vice President Joe Biden
the Democratic frontrunner he Bernie
Sanders and eight more Democrats are on
stage tonight
Anthony Biden's name conspicuously
absent head thank you